the very original first leaker of the  notch for the 14 and 16 inch macbook  pros just gave us new information that  the laptop that we are expecting in the  march event looks to be a base model  macbook pro that is going to retain the  same 13-inch design and screen our first  issue is that apple is putting a brand  new chip into a very old design the  second issue is that as soon as the  macbook air comes out this would give  this laptop a usable kind of lifespan of  about six months before it just feels  even more outdated the third issue is  that if apple does keep this old design  they are not going to be able to raise  the price point from its current base  1299 up to say 13.99 or 14.99 which is  what we expected if they will go ahead  and use the 14-inch chassis and then  maybe remove some of the options